il ya des barrières qui tentent des
barrières un peu mentale en fait une
fois que ces barrières l'est sont tombés
qu'on sait que on est capable de faire
plein de trucs
il ya plein d'horizon qui s'ouvre et on
était très très loin de s'imaginer que
deux ans plus tard on aurait un prix de
l'institut français du design par
exemple c'est des choses comme ça qui
sont marrantes et qui font plaisir
il ya quelque chose je pense d'assez
puissant en fait de mettre des gens qui
a priori ont des difficultés socio
économiques dans des dispositions où ils
vont pouvoir faire avec leurs mains où
ils vont pouvoir être valorisés où ils
vont pouvoir progresser aussi dans
l'acquisition de compétences où ils vont
pouvoir aussi retrouver des formes de
socialisation leur permettre de ré
accéder à une forme de normalité
donc effectivement on peut se dire c'est
une honte et de la menuiserie cdu c'est
du travail du bois mais c'est pas comme
ça quoi un combat qu'il nous faut mener
même en temps de paix si tu as la foi
c'est tu croises en toi tiens le kobo
vieux lutte de ton mur
lève toi et marche
il prend bien garde aux marches comme
vos faux amis que ton look ennuis
[Musique]